[Music]
the option to use active duty forces in
a law enforcement role should only be
used as a matter of last resort
and only in the most urgent and dire of
situations
we are not in one of those situations
now
i do not support invoking the
insurrection act if a city or state
refuses to take the actions that are
necessary to defend the life and
property
of their residents then i will deploy
the united states military
and quickly solve the problem for them
well the defense secretary mark esper
breaking ranks uh today
saying what he said to reporters this
afternoon then late in the afternoon
returning reversing a
decision to send some 200 active duty
military
that are around the washington d.c area
back to their home base
what now there are reports that the
white house
the administration the president upset
with asper what's going to happen let's
bring in our panel mo alethe
executive director of the georgetown
institute of politics maura lions and
national political correspondent of
national public radio
and former white house press secretary
ari fleischer
maura was interesting to watch this a
press conference kind of a
walk back of sorts and then a change
yeah i was stunned actually i wouldn't
have expected the defense secretary to
break with the president like this
i don't really understand what the later
move to to
uh bring back those troops means but
he read from a statement this was not
off the cuff he is breaking with the
president on the insurrection act
he also has clearly had second thoughts
about accompanying the president on that
walk through lafayette park he did refer
to it as a photo
op um it's hard to imagine how he can
stay on in the cabinet after this but
we'll see i mean the white house was
very careful today
kaylee mcenany did not say the president
had faith in him
just we have to wait to see what happens
ari you've been through administrations
were there turnover of different
officials but now you have a former
defense secretary the first defense
secretary for president trump
with this scathing commentary in the
atlantic
jim mattis saying donald trump is the
first president of my lifetime who does
not
try to unite the american people does
not even pretend to try
instead he tries to divide us he goes on
in a pretty lengthy
article ari what do you what do you make
of this a deliberate effort he says of
drawing the country apart
scathing is right i mean that piece was
very tough on the president
and it got right to the greatest fault
line in our society uh
how divisive the president can be how
divisive the times we live in are
i think people are equally divisive back
to the president but
clearly for general mathis he reached
his breaking point and
he is uncomfortable what he's seeing
it's extraordinary that a former member
of the president's cabinet
would criticize the man who gave him
that position
in such blunt terms
it's a sign of the trouble that the
president is in you know you don't want
to be a president where you have such
great
division where you're losing former
allies especially in an election year so
i do think this is a troublesome sign
of people who once supported the
president
you know the law and order pitch the
president says you have to
dominate the streets mo uh you've heard
the former vice president
uh denounce uh the rioting and the
looting
but obviously support protesters the
president said similar words about
a peaceful protest but it seems like
it's
it's kind of one versus the other uh
now how do you see this as we get ready
for this election
yeah and i think one of the challenges
the president has
is he says the right things about
peaceful protests
but then in front of the whole world
with cameras rolling
authorizes militarized law enforcement
to to use excessive force against
peaceful protesters
on his way to the church so it's a real
problem look i
get why the president is speaking about
law and order
right i'm i may be a democrat but i
don't like the writing in the streets
that needs to stop those people need to
be need to be fully prosecuted
but you know not at the expense of our
ability to
peacefully protest and i think where the
president may be
miscalculating a bit is while the tough
law and order
comments he may he may believe can help
him politically
i think there's something that's a
little bit more defining right now for a
lot of people and that is chaos
that is a complete and total sense of
chaos
in our government where the president is
trying to deal with two
incredibly difficult crises with a
pandemic
and the racial trouble and the riots
two incredibly difficult situations
and can't get his hands around them
right this seems to be getting away from
our federal government
and on top of that the economy is
starting to go into free fall so
the the the political calculus may be
that
law and order works but i think there
are a lot of folks out there who are
just saying i'm done with the chaos we
need
a steady hand of leadership well you
know that last part the economy going to
free fall there are positive signs uh
that
actually the job losses are less than
predicted and the market really loved
that today
uh so there may be kind of turn in the
corner we'll see how the rest of the
week looks
here is the president talking to brian
kilmeade this morning
they burned down the church the day
before i heard how nice and wonderful
the protesters were over there really
then why did they burn down the church
the day before they didn't use tear gas
they didn't use they moved them out now
when i went
i didn't say oh move them out i didn't
know who was there i figured i was going
to walk over the church very nearby
most religious leaders loved it mara
you know they didn't use tear gas they
used pepper spray pellets
they used people's about what was used
but
they cleared them yeah i mean they
cleared them out
there was smoke in the air and people
were coughing and and and tearing up
look the president has been trying to
send two messages it's just that one is
much louder than the other the law and
order message
um versus the the healing message he
actually has a youtube
ad up today with his remarks
from the space launch which were all
about healing
um but you don't hear that what you hear
is the tough law-order message in terms
of religious leaders loving it there
were a lot of religious leaders who
criticized it including the religious
leaders whose church that is
so you know the president is trying to
have it both ways
and maybe it'll work i mean in the past
law and order messages have worked for
republicans and against democrats when
there are violent protests
but you know moe made a really important
point president is not just
the low law order president he is the
president of chaos
and disruption and that's something that
people might just be exhausted by
yeah arya it was just interesting to see
all the pushback about that walk across
the street
um obviously from even the
the religious leaders from that church
but not a lot of
talk about the burning church we talked
about that last night but last word here
yeah can you imagine if the tea party
surrounded the white house when
president obama was in office and
the worst elements burnt down and burnt
the basement of saint john's church
across the street from the white house
and president obama said i want to go
visit that church and they moved people
away so he could visit he would be
praised by the media for sending every
right message what a hero
and you know the press would be all over
those tea party protesters at the white
house
and they would say it's entirely
appropriate that the white house the
secret service i'm sorry
moved the protester so the president
could go to the church with his bible
this is hypocrisy of the highest order i
thought frankly
bret the president going to the church
he marched for people who want to go to
church there's another part of the
symbolism of that
quite important
okay we'll see how this plays big
picture thank you all i got to run
i got to run though okay
i know you think it was a bad stunt and
you you've made your point clear i get
it
and i we have all sides here but i gotta
run because a commercial break